you know uh uh as a kid
who grew up in a christian environment
okay in iran which you couldn't be and i
was an atheist till i was 25 years old
this whole concept about god's watching
you watching everything you do you know
how parents put that fear in there and
they would say the famous line mommy may
not know what you did but god does
you know
dad may not know what you're doing god's
watching you okay
and then you learn about free will which
free will is what the ability to
do whatever i want to do and then you
know if i commit a crime guess what i go
to jail for it but if i break something
i'm going to suffer some consequences
but the free will is there the concern
becomes we are more and more going
towards
the government wanting to be more
powerful than god where the free will is
taken out
that's a little concerning where i don't
have the ability to make a decision for
myself because of an opinion you gave
that may influence me in a way and i'm
not talking about your world i'm talking
more
uh
what happened during covet specifically
how censorship was at a high and yeah
this person is being censored that
person is being censored you saw the
other day with babylon b
put a story out there and twitter
wouldn't uh reinstate you know bring
them back up and reactivate them and
babylon b's founder him and i were
communicating over the weekend
they stuck to the ground and we said
we're not doing it and now they're not
on twitter but
harmony is on twitter a lot of putin's
still on twitter and they're doing what
they're doing to the world so i think
the concern with a lot of technologies
that like yourself again i wish
my goal today was to have two cia agents
here with us okay to have a conversation
maybe
maybe we'll do that next time but to
kind of get them because
one of them was all in for what you're
doing
when i tell you all in 100 all in for
what you're doing he says believe me
america needs what those guys are
working on okay there's only a few
things that they have to be careful with
he kind of talked about the automated
decision making he just didn't use those
words he explained in a different way
the other one said
that uh
he believes we're going in this
direction whether we like it or not it's
just who's in charge and running this
okay so icity and i talked you know i
said okay nice guy they don't watch any
tv till 14 reader gaming coder that's
what you did later on you built games
you did what you you're kind of messing
around with certain things you didn't
like authority telling you what to do
you kind of are the guy that if somebody
tells you can't do it you do do it so
i'm assuming you're probably the guy the
more these lawsuits you get in a weird
way i feel you get more excited you're
like come on down you know push us more
try to silence us
hosting the world's first ever lawyer
appreciation day yeah in june in new
york city so you are yeah really that's
why i told our lawyers it's like look
you know
we're going to do this for you and
they've never had it before and they
said your appreciation day
oh my god
i've never heard a lawyer appreciation
day they need to have them they but for
me they're some of the best in their
field i get to learn from them i never
had to deal with lawyers on this level
but now
it's really interesting well i'm sure
they love you man that's like a big
endorsement for lawyers because
we aren't necessary yeah but uh like
floyd abrams for example he's um very
he's famous for defending the new york
times in the pentagon papers case a very
strong first amendment case against the
government he's one of our lawyers right
he took on our case because he feels
that like this is public information it
should be out used by anybody would you
want to live in a world where any of
these companies can send a cease and
desist like facebook google and they
dictate what's in the public square i
don't think that's the kind of the right
world there
so um yeah we're hosting the world's
first ever lawyer appreciation day it's
gonna be a lot of fun we have a red
carpet photos i know your appreciation
day well i think you're gonna need the
best lawyers and i think you're gonna
need to
keep lawyered up for a long time to do
what you're doing because but we attract
the best people in each field but anyway
back to what you were saying about you
know who's
running things and i
your censorship issue is a big issue
right and i think that these companies
have more and more power over time you
have twitter you have facebook and
they've been say more powerful than a
newspaper because they can
take someone's account away or you know
take information off for whatever reason
they want but i think in a lot of ways
the system we're working in is evolving
right it learns from new information and
that it could be around now a lot of
these uh mandates found mosques and code
have been lifted because you know a lot
of politicians look at re-election and
they say okay most people don't want to
have these on all the time so um
i think we're coming out a lot of the
covert crisis and things that happened
there so we it was great about america
it's very dynamic place right and the
system that's set up with the
judiciary and the congress and the
executive branch it there's a lot of
balance of power and so things do swing
back and forth and i think that's what
makes it great because you do have you
know it takes the best out of its
population and turns them into like
great entrepreneurs and things like that
so i think still a special place and
there's always going to be concerns
about those things especially around
censorship it's a big deal or you know
things that
could be over the top from you know the
executive branch but you know
things go back and forth and um and
we're here we're still talking and you
know your show's still in the air i'm
still allowed to be here if you enjoyed
this short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]